6 months ago we heard that TSM was
pulling their League of Legends team out
of the LCS and moving it to another tier
one region we've heard basically nothing
about that since though and with the
season now over and a new one right
around the corner everyone is asking
where the hell are
TSM thanks to our friends over at Rog
for sponsoring this video here's Demitri
to tell you more about their Black
Friday sale all right so before we get
into the video just a quick heads up
that this year our friends over at Rog
are having a banger Black Friday sale
only on Amazon we actually partnered
with Rog For an upcoming crack that you
have to check out Colton and I got to
build a tricked out PC to test out rog's
brand new state-of-the-art 540 HZ
monitor now that thing is a monster but
let me tell you rog's 300hz stricks xg2
7 a qmr is also very Beastly so if
you're in the market for a gorgeous
top-of-the-line 1440p display with a
fast response IPS panel that produces
eye wateringly vibrant colors make sure
you head over to Amazon to check out
this exclusive 15% off Black Friday sale
it is a sick monitor for an even sicker
price so be sure to check it out now
back to the video okay then so do you
remember this from back in may we have
made a tough decision to start the
process of transitioning to an another
tier one region this may feel sudden but
to be honest we've been actively working
towards this for the last 3 years I
believe moving to another region will'll
reignite our hunger to doing whatever it
takes to win a world championship that
was TSM CEO Reggie announcing that their
League of Legends team would be leaving
the LCS and moving to a different tier
one region or if you have been following
North America's International track
record an actual tier one region I'm
kidding just kidding that announcement
came years after sliding results for
tsm's league team a once totally
dominant force in North America that
began struggling to qualify for worlds
and then spectacularly bombed out in
2020 when they finally did life for a
moment at start of the ulti channel
there flash engage for Broken Blade they
want in sl's going to save one will it
be enough though or horn comes out will
not find the knockup an ulti backwards
now for Broken Blade five on five still
happening Rascal gets hooked in stone
plate will time out can TSM find the
first kill Speaker going to get in that
is a fiveman sleep if TSM can't win this
what will they add to that the financial
concerns now some of this was shared by
all Esports orgs it's no secret that the
industry has had quite a rocky return to
reality after a decade of inflated
evaluation absurd operational costs and
eye watering player salaries and
specifically for TSM in 2022 they
suspended their $210 million naming
rights deal with FTX after the crypto
Marketplace filed for bankruptcy amidst
allegations of misuse of customer
deposits and an investigation by the US
justice department there were rumors
that TSM were planning to pull out of a
number of their traditional Esports
scenes for a lot of fans though it
didn't feel like TSM were dropping their
league team because Reggie had clearly
stated the team was simply moving to a
different region this sentiment was also
evident on September 30th of this year
the day of their last LCS game where TSM
thank their fans around the world and
the LCS For The Memories they also said
their Journey towards championships had
not ended and so TSM fans have waited
with baited breath for an announcement
any announcement at all about when and
where their league team will return but
so far there's been nothing some fans
have been hoping that Reggie will do
what he's done in the past at times and
emerge in a random TSM thread on Reddit
to shed some light on the or's plans
earlier this week there was hope that
the end of worlds and the opening of the
player signing period would Herald an
announcement about the future but in the
absence of official news fans have been
left speculating among themselves first
off what region are they moving to well
there have been rumors circulating for
quite a while now back in July 2022
dexerto reported that TSM had made
inquiries at the time about acquiring
the recently sold Misfits franchise slot
in the LEC in May this year reporter
Jacob wolf revealed he'd heard ti7 have
been talking to LPL orgs as far back as
November 2022 the truth is we don't know
it could be Europe China or South Korea
so for the moment perhaps a better
question to ask is what would TSM in any
of those leagues actually look like
spots in tier one regions don't grow on
trees teams aren't that willing to give
them up and they also come with tier one
price tags to match so one prevailing
theory is that TSM has approached an
existing European South Korean or
Chinese team for a partnership they
might not be actively involved in the
day-to-day Esports operations of that
team but the team would carry the TSM
branding partially or in full the appeal
for the host team is quite clear they
become the focus of tsm's global fan
base and be able to benefit from the
monetization of that they'd receive a
lump sum when signing the deal and
consistent Financial backing thereafter
they'd likely be mostly autonomous too
although to what degree would depend on
the nature of the deal in return firstly
TSM would have their brand present in a
major region where viewership is either
growing stable or at the very least
decreasing more slowly than in the LCS
also TSM have said all along that their
reason for doing this is that they want
to win championships they want to make
this move and then eventually go on and
win Worlds How likely is this well some
of you guys might be laughing right now
and thinking they have absolutely no
chance but at first glance it kind of
has to be more likely than if they just
stayed in the LCS we could sit here and
debate the reasons for that all day but
the bottom line is no LCS team has even
got a sniff of the Summoners cup in the
past decade and yes I'm including the
2018 Cloud 19 there but moving to a top
region is no guarantee of success either
presuming TSM Partners up with a
mid-table team in one of those regions I
can't see them going toe to- toe in
their first year with the likes of jdg
with T1 geni G2 I just can't it may even
take a couple of seasons for TSM to even
qualify for worlds in one of those
regions and what if they can't even do
that if TSM ends up languishing as a
middle of the pack team in the LPL among
16 others all but forgotten by their
Western fans and struggling to make
playoffs would it even have been worth
it for them or their fans of course it
may also go amazingly maybe they qualify
for Worlds at the first time of asking
and get to quarterfinals maybe they keep
the bulk of their North American fans
and open up a whole new market in the
process maybe but this is all
speculation and Wishful Thinking at the
moment and that's all TSM fans have to
go on in the absence of actual
announcements and plans the path ahead
may be uncertain for them but there is a
feeling among TSM fans that whatever the
future holds the decision to leave the
LCS was the right one recently the LCS
announced theyd be downsizing from 10 to
eight teams for next season with golden
Guardians and Evil Geniuses parting from
the league for some LCS fans this has
confirmed their suspicions that the
league is in a downward spiral that its
profitability its stability and
sustainability are in deep Jeopardy now
there was a time about a decade ago
where the LCS did in fact have eight
teams before expanding to 10 but that
won't calm the nerves of many LCS fans
the story of Esports so far has been one
of growth where people are accustomed to
seeing their product get bigger and
better every year not return to where
they started and for investors will they
want to pump money into a league that
has the potential to shrink even further
remember TSM reportedly sold their LCS
spot to Shopify Rebellion this year for
$10 million compare that to the 30
million plus paid by Evil Geniuses to
Echo Fox for their slot less than 4
years earlier and you can see why there
might be some concerns that the value of
an LCS slot may not appreciate from here
Riot have said the move from 10 to8
teams in the LCS will allow them to be
more flexible whatever that means but
will it halt the trend of consistent
viewership decline over the past 3 years
amidst all these questions TSM fans are
stying to see their org's decision to
leave the LCS as jumping before
it's too late at the time TSM were met
with derision by some in the LCS
Community who felt like the or was
abandoning the league that made them
what they are and now some TSM fans see
the recent LCS downsizing as borderline
Vindication of the or's decision to
leave but that Vindication is pretty
much all they have and even that is
contingent on tsm's plans to join a
different region actually going ahead
it's not easy to Simply Shuffle over to
a new region in League of Legends even
if it's a partnership deal and TSM may
have already hit a few hurdles since
their bold announcement in May perhaps
it's more expensive than Reggie first
imagined perhaps they're not sure if
they'll be able to qualify for and
especially win worlds in a new region
perhaps it's bigger than their league
team and simply doesn't make Financial
or marketing sense for the org as a
whole but we don't know the fans don't
know they haven't known anything for
half a year now only TSM and Reggie
knows what the future of their league
team looks like at this point and the
longer their silence the louder the
question where the hell at
TSM I think whatever
happens from here on in with TSM it's
going to be an insane story like if they
actually go to a new region and they do
amazingly you know they qualify for
worlds they do really well at Worlds
Maybe even win it in 5 years that would
be such an insane story and if they
crash and
burn that's going to be hell of a story
too you know I think everyone just kind
of wants to see which way it's going to
go um I don't know I don't know at this
point